wer weiß schon frühmorgens jeden tag
er weiß schon heute wogen sind immer
wieder als neubeginn
hey leute
wir haben dieses jahr diesen sommer
leider nicht geschafft in urlaub zu
fahren aber das ist überhaupt kein
problem wir haben unseren guten freund
der uns hier ein gehörten hat zu seinem
campingplatz zu kommen
und hier dürfen wir unsere zelte
aufschlagen
da ich zu meinem platz gefahren das
schwierigste am campen ist natürlich das
zelt aufzubauen
wir haben nur ein posten für den eingang
wir haben kein problem weil ich habe ja
ein messer dabei
da gehe ich jetzt einfach mal im wald
davor und schnitzt und schnell irgendwas
schönes tier in herning
damit machen wir das zelt im boden fest
das ganze land geld gibt's heute ist
holland frankreich unsere nachbarn waren
spanier glaube ich sehr bunt gemixt mit
so einer satellitenschüssel kann man
auch fußball ihren campingplatz
anschauen so ein wohnmobil der ich noch
keiner wir wohl nutzen wohnmobile machen
dann mobile studio draußen sie ich gebe
mir dann hier drauf wir machen später
schon noch musik wer auf jeden fall
hast du dann die gitarre dabei ohne
gitarre gehe ich doch nicht zum campen
basieren
wir wollen auf jeden fall noch mal danke
gesagt dass du uns hier eingeladen
gerne hätte ich ja selber wenn man sich
hier umschaut sind ja ganz schön viele
menschen die deutschland als wären sie
schon ihr ganzes leben lang also würden
sie geboten
die schon länger hier sind um auch hier
wohnen
das kostet es dann das ganze jahr hier
zu sein hergestellt was kostet momentan
1050 und dann gibt es noch so neben
kostenpauschale nachdem wie oft die da
sind okay die sind aus dem norden von
deutschland die wurden meisten zeit hier
in die 2 die sind aus dem ehemaligen
osten diesen hier bei einer baufirma
angestellt und arbeiten hier halt unter
der woche waren am wochenende nach hause
ohne scheu 2gb wohnen in münchen und am
wochenende raus so wie wir mit unseren
sorry damit euren teilt das schön und
sich zurückzuziehen
so stelle ich mir camping vorher ich
habe die jungs mir gezeigt wie man feuer
schnell gekriegt würstchen lollis noch
vorbeigekommen spielt uns jetzt noch
einen kleinen song vor und wir genießen
auf den abend bis bald
17 hier ein lagerfeuer jetzt den jungs
die würstchen sind glaube ich fertig so
habe ich mir das vorgestellt